joining us from the government this
morning the technology minister chris
philp minister great to have you on the
program this morning but clearly these
are these are very concerning times
given that the troop build up around
ukraine uh president biden has warned
ukraine's president to prepare for
impact are we really that close to
conflict in your opinion
well we're deeply concerned the buildup
of russian troops around the ukrainian
border has reached unprecedented levels
military units from the far east of
russia have moved into that region
something that hasn't happened for many
many years previously
so i think it is a very serious
situation i think president biden and
our prime minister are right to warn
president putin that the consequences if
they do
invade ukraine will be very very serious
indeed for russia in terms of sanctions
the americans made clear yesterday that
the nordstrom 2 pipe
would not happen if they invade uh in
the united kingdom we're doing
everything we can to support the
ukrainians including supplying uh
military equipment that would help them
and training as well that goes with that
that would help them prevent tanks
russian tanks from entering ukrainian
territory so i think we are urging uh
russia to
get to the table uh to discuss
issues uh that are relevant and to
de-escalate this situation which will
ultimately de-escalation is clearly in
the interests of all concerned uh it is
not too late to de-escalate and that is
what now needs to happen
yeah we will certainly see over there in
the coming days and weeks that the tone
struck by vladimir putin and i do
however want to move on to more domestic
matters minister uh given we have you on
the program this morning
and national insurance and in various
interviews this week ministers from the
cabinet down have all insisted that that
planned increase come april is going to
go ahead yesterday the prime minister
didn't confirm it i'm just wondering
what is your understanding of the
situation right now is that national
national insurance rise in april set in
stone
uh yes it is going ahead it was approved
by the whole cabinet it was passed by
parliament
with a significant
majority and the money is needed to fund
the nhs which is something i think that
is a national priority it's 36 billion
pounds over three years to fund the nhs
and social care
we need to put that money in to make
sure the nhs has the resources it needs
to recover after the pandemic and this
is a
proportionate way of finding that money
we are of course though all of this has
to be considered against the backdrop of
rising energy prices that
energy price cap uh coming out in what
just over a week's time when are we
going to hear more from the government
in this and your colleague james heapey
speaking on television last night said
the government is in listening more than
all of this when are we going to hear
more from the government about the
financial assistance that may be made
available as we we head into some very
very expensive times
yeah just on the national insurance
point it's worth keeping in mind that
the six and a half million people on the
lowest incomes won't pay a single extra
penny as a result of that and half of
the extra money paid will be paid by the
14 of top earners so it's just worth
keeping that in mind
on your broader question about cost of
living yes the government absolutely is
in listening mode about the general
broader cost of living issues there are
lots of measures in place already to
help address that i mean the cost of
living issue by the way is clearly a
global issue inflation in america is
higher than it is here it's higher in
germany than it is here as well it's a
global phenomenon but we do need to take
action so for example there is already a
big increase in the minimum wage planned
for april it's going up
to nine pounds fifty an hour an increase
that is well above the rate of inflation
we've already announced that the the
universal credit taper is being extended
which will put an extra thousand pounds
a year into the pockets of families on
uh lower income so all and there are a
huge number of interventions happening
on energy prices so for example uh
there's the the things like the winter
fuel allowance we've had for many years
there's also a half billion pound fund
established already to help people uh on
lower incomes with their fuel bills and
but i suspect there will be uh even more
uh done in the coming coming weeks and
months but in a targeted way to make
sure people who need some assistance
with things like fuel bills um can get
that but a lot has been done already
i wonder if we can turn our attention to
afghanistan you may well have heard us
reporting the fact that the foreign
office is is giving an additional 100
million pounds aid which i'm sure those
in afghanistan will be crying out for
but but yesterday the accusation was
made that the prime minister was
ultimately responsible for signing off
on the repatriation of of animals over
afghans he described
that allegation yesterday
as total rhubarb
what on earth did he mean by that
well i think he meant that the
allegation was not true i think that's
what he meant when he said well why
didn't you say the minister wasn't
involved in well i think he wasn't
involved in making uh individual uh
decisions and uh you know we should also
be clear by the way um that the plane
which those people and animals came out
on was not a plane that was commissioned
or chartered by the uk government it was
done privately by by donors but i think
the prime minister's made his uh
position on this very clear
it wasn't something that he was uh
personally involved in
and we should bother you
i just want i want to focus on the
language because i keep hearing that the
prime minister is gifted in its use i'm
just wondering whether or not you think
describing it as total rhubarb is is
respectful to the afghan interpreters
that we left behind some of whom are now
dead
well i think what we should be clear
about in terms of the afghan situation
is that last august in that emergency
situation the united kingdom evacuated
far more people from afghanistan than
any other european country we did it in
very short order we provided troops on
the ground to protect that air base in
kabul so i think we can be extremely
proud of what we did in afghanistan and
now we're running a program over a
five-year period that will see more
at-risk afghan civilians including or
particularly women and girls resettled
into the uk
in large 20 000 people that again that
is more than any other european country
so the fact the united kingdom has
helped and will help okay more afghans
than any other european country is
something we can be enormously proud of
yeah i understand that but despite the
fact that we have emails from the
foreign office letters from
boris johnson's then pps the prime
minister describes the allegation that
he authorized this as as total rhubarb
i'll repeat that so if the prime
minister didn't authorise it who did
well he was the prime minister wasn't
involved in making operational decisions
the plane as i said was actually
chartered privately in terms of the uh
operational decision making about who
had access to the uh the airstrip the
airfield and who got into the perimeter
of it and those would have been
operational decisions i don't know
exactly which person would have been
controlling that on a day-to-day basis
well they were working on they were
working on that together both of those
departments but let me just be clear
again the united kingdom evacuated more
people from afghanistan in august than
any other european country and we can be
extremely proud of that
i i understand that but if the prime
minister is telling us despite the
evidence that we can all see with their
own eyes where he is named in an email
from the foreign office as having
authorized this if he didn't authorize
it who did
i think it's a fairly significant
question
i've i've explained already that those
operational decisions about um on the
ground were being taken by uh teams
working in the foreign office
operationally the ministry of defense
obviously were uh in control with the
americans of kabul airport the prime
minister's been clear that it wasn't the
decision he was
involved in
i think whoever wrote that email it was
obviously a sort of second or third hand
account uh clearly it was um mistaken
and as i say the efforts we made in
afghanistan in august and that we're
making now over the next now and over
the next few years
are leading europe and that is something
we should be proud of
sure
minister i suppose the point the broader
point in all of this is that there are
legitimate concerns about the prime
minister's capacity for telling the
truth at the moment of his moral probity
in fact you yourself were openly mocked
by the audience and on bbc's any
questions uh when the host asked you if
boris johnson was a beacon of moral
integrity i mean do you stand by that do
you honestly believe mr johnson to be a
beacon of moral integrity
yeah yes i do and i said he's someone
who is working night and day and has
been since he became prime minister two
and a half years ago
to he's delivered brexit which obviously
people thought was difficult or
impossible he did that he won a
landslide general election victory uh
we've since been hit by covid and he and
his team have been working night and day
to get us through this pandemic as a
result of which we've had a world
european leading
booster programme we've got more payroll
jobs now 400 000 more than before the
pandemic youth unemployment at a record
low the imf came out this week
forecasting that we would have the
highest growth in this country of any g7
country of any g7 economy none of that
is an accident it's happened as a result
of enormous amounts of hard work that
have been led by the prime minister and
i think the results uh speak louder than
words and the results the prime minister
has delivered for this country in
extraordinarily difficult circumstances
are something that he and his team the
government and frankly all of us can be
proud of
just just finally and very very briefly
i do need to let you go um as of this
moment as a quarter past seven uh on a
friday morning the suit report has not
yet been handed to downing street is
that your understanding
uh well i spoke to someone in downing
street uh about half an hour ago and
they certainly didn't indicate that it
had been received so uh i i you know i
don't know a lot more than you do but
i've certainly got no information as of
right now that it's been received
mr thanks very much for joining us this
morning appreciate it